Hey traders, it's Mike here and I'm
going to show you the stupidly simple
5-second chart read that is going to
blow your mind, right? It It Imagine
it's not 5 minutes of analysis, it's
literally just 5 seconds. All you got to
do is pull up a footprint chart, look at
the high, you look at the low, or as
we're making the highs or lows, watch
what's happening to those highs and
lows. You know, here this is the um
bonds going up today up today, hit this
high, boom, got a exhaustion print,
market sold off, got within a couple of
ticks of the low. What made this high so
special? Well, we have an exhaustion
print up here, all right? So, if you're
looking at a bar chart, you're not going
to know that there's exhaustion up here,
right? You're just going to see a red
down candle. But, if you're looking at a
footprint chart, you can identify that
with the volume there, and specifically
if you're using Order Flow Suite Trader,
you know, we have a template made just
so that you can see the exhaustion
prints. We call it uh the the exhaustion
template. It's really simple, easy to
use, you just load it on your chart, and
it just shows up right here. Very easy
to see, very easy to identify. You know,
you don't have to sit there and try to
analyze each tick that's going through
at each price level. All you got to do
is you just wait till it fires off up
there. Um this is the uh bonds today.
You know, ultra bonds had a real
textbook
um example trade today.
Uh let's pull up the ultra bonds really
quick here. You know, bonds and ultra
bonds, you know, they obviously they
move very similar.
Um here you got the exhaustion print of
just one, right? I mean, that's it
doesn't get any more
uh exhaustive than just one contract
trading. And, you know, this was the
piece of advice that was given to me
way back in the 1990s by Tom DeMark
before Well, it was right around the
time he released his books, you know, he
was going on these uh tours with uh CQG
to different cities, and I happened to
uh
have the uh for good fortune to meet up
with him, and we were talking about uh
Micron of all things.
and you know he kept saying Micron was
going to go to zero.
And I'm like how do you know? He says
well the last buyer has bought, right?
There's no one interested in buying
anymore. And that was just something
that sort of stuck with me for a long
time and you know when I worked at
places like uh
Dean Witter, Commerce Bank, JP Morgan,
you know when we're trading on the old
Globex systems, you know watching the
dome, we would watch how highs or lows
were made and how much volume traded
there. And you know sometimes you would
see something just like this, a high
tick, one contract trade and then
the selling come in, right? And we we
knew that you know sellers weren't
interested anymore because only
one person bought it, they were testing
the market, they were trying to probe to
see if there was anybody else up there
um
that was going to buy along with them
and if that if nobody was interested in
buying with them, we know that then
there's probably nobody else interested
in buying as as well. And then you can
see the market uh reverse.
In
E-minis today, uh let's just sort of
take a look here getting back to uh when
the cash opened here. Let's just uh
scroll back.
Um okay, so again using the same
template
that I'm using in in bonds.
Just before the cash open
you know there would it did fire off a a
buy signal but again you know this is
8:24, you got about 5-6 minutes before
the cash opens. I don't suggest taking
any trades right ahead of the cash open.
Um cuz you know what's going to happen,
right? You're going to have a tight stop
here. Cash is going to open even though
the trade worked out, there's a lot of
volatility coming into the market, a lot
of orders coming into the market and
what you just saw happen here on this
open, right? It
went down, there was some selling
pressure early and then the market made
the move that you're looking for. Again
you know, it's
for me I I I wouldn't take any trade
just right ahead of the cash open. Let
the cash open
take place and then
then you can trade. You just look for
your trades. And him
not that long after the cash open, 8:40,
so about 10 minutes after the cash open,
we got our exhaustion print up here, 10
contracts. Okay? And where are you going
to get short? You're going to get short
right here. Your stop's just going to go
right up here.
>> [gasps]
>> Next bar didn't go any lower, but the
bar after that did get you short and
started to trade down. Now, it sort of
went back up, got within a couple of
ticks of the high and about three ticks
off your stop, didn't quite get there.
You know, again, you got a four
contracts up here, so you know, you
know, buying aggressive buying's getting
a bit weaker. And then market started um
going down. Now,
this level here, let's just uh
take a closer look at these levels just
so you get an idea.
Okay, so, you know, where you going to
be getting short at? 7508 and 3/4. Your
stop up there at 16 and a half, so
it's about eight
six Yeah, eight to 16 is That's what?
Eight points of risk.
Okay? And again, you know, it got within
it got did get within three ticks of
your
of your stop price,
but once it started moving, it had a
nice move down. Okay? So, again, you
know, it was a little bit slow to start.
And you know, it just sort of went up,
came down.
You know, getting short around 8:50,
it's, you know, kind of in your favor,
kind of not in your favor. Nothing wrong
with getting out here around 02 if you
can or 03 or 04. Um you know, it just
went sideways for a bit longer. I talked
about this yesterday. Um
you don't want to keep holding it too
long even though it did drop down to,
you know, 88.
So, you know, if you're getting short up
there, uh what do we say it was eight
and 3/4 up here, did get down to 88. So,
that This is 20 points right here. Um
but again, you You you'd have to hold it
through there. I find the best moves
happen uh
quicker sooner rather than later. It did
get down to 78 and 3/4. So, you know,
there's another 10 points lower. But
again, how long you going to hold on to
this trade? Um you know, me I I I'd just
rather just
take my profit, cut it, wait for another
trade. You know, there was other
opportunities in other markets. I so
showed you the bonds and the ultra
bonds. Um and it wasn't till a bit later
in the day.
You know, it's the Friday ahead of
Memorial Day weekend. You know, market
was just sort of trading kind of quiet.
And then around 12:20,
we got a couple of more signals came in
here, right? At this swing low, get a
buy signal, okay? Again, where you going
to get long? Just above the high of the
entry bar. Your stops just going to go
right down here. You get long here. This
time it barely pulls back. It just pulls
back about two points, right in here,
before it rallies all the way up to new
highs. And again, you know, what is this
level? You know, you're getting in at
around 75.08
and a half. Gets all the way up to 24. I
mean, that was the high. But you know,
from eight up to 18, that's 10 points
right there.
Then you get your bearish signal. So,
even if you got long here and you know,
it makes that run up, you get your
bearish signal right here.
Confirms it here at 18 anyway. So, you
know, if you were long, you got to get
out here cuz now you've got the bearish
signal to get short.
At 18 thereabouts, and then it starts
trading down. Again, gets down to uh you
know, 12, 13.
Whoops.
Then, you know,
just sort of hangs around that area,
still in the money, before it sort of
breaks down. You know, today was a bit
quiet. I do think so because of the
holiday.
Um
you know, the the moves took longer to
develop. You know, it was much nicer in
the ultra bonds where it was just pretty
straight
straight down over the the the hour that
you're in the trade. And again, there's
no reason to get out, you know, if
trade's going in your favor, stick with
it. But if the trade, like here in the
S&P's is just sort of hanging around
this area,
you got to consider, you know, do you
want to stay with it or do you want to
cut it? Okay? I mean, here you could
have had a small profit.
Okay? So, you know, instead of getting
10 points, you got
you know, you shorted 18, maybe getting
out around, you know, anywhere here, 15,
16.
Okay? But it did get down to, you know,
down here to
>> [sighs]
>> you know, this is seven, eight, you
know, this is the eight area, 7508 in
here.
Where this is 08's, so that would be 10
points if if you
wanted to hold it longer. There's
nothing wrong with holding it longer as
long as it's like I said, as long as
it's in your favor,
you can hold it longer, but if it's just
hanging around break even, I don't
necessarily recommend that.
Um I think that was it. I mean, I think
there was one leap in the day. You know,
this one, 2:32 in the afternoon, we got
30 minutes left before the cash closes.
And again, similar thing, it it just
started going up right here. You get
into the trade.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine. Again, this is your entry
price. Then it sort of comes down in
here
before it would have come down here and
stop you out. How long do you want to
stay in the trade?
It's starting to make a move, sort of
came down here, gave you some
opportunities to get out. But again, by
this time, you know, you you you're
getting in the trade at 2:32, 10 minutes
puts it around
2:42.
Cash market is going to close soon.
Okay, we don't know
um you know, how much volatility that's
going to happen right ahead of the cash
close, you know, if the market can make
a run.
Um, you know, and it just sort of came
down here then it just went back up. So
again, you know,
understanding where you are in the
trading day, you know, right ahead of
the cash close,
would you want to take a trade looking
for a decent move? Maybe. Um, but
definitely not like that one that I
showed you right before the um, cash
open.
But I I just want to also wanted to show
you
um, euro currency, okay? Cuz euro
currency was
interesting today
in the sense that
there's two losing trades um, on the
eight range chart that I like to use in
the in the euro currency.
And these are just unfortunate trades. I
mean, that's how it is in trading
sometimes, okay?
Because you know, I showed you a lot of
examples of of trades that worked
beautifully, but sometimes this happens,
right? You got your exhaustion print
here
and down here.
This one
there was just a little bit of buying
left here. Whoops, right here. Um, so
you're you know, your stop's just right
here and it trades just four ticks
through your stop before it makes that
run. So, you know, it gets you in right
here and it just a little bit of buying
left come up, stop you out and then make
that move. Unlucky.
Um, you know, in terms of delta, you
know, you're you're going up, right? I
mean, there there was a big buyer here
sitting on the bid, 639,
you know, which
you know, make of it what you will, but
we did come down, trade through it, so
he wasn't there anymore. It's just there
was just a bit of buying left over that
it just popped it up there, high ticked
you, stopped enough to stop you out. Um,
you know, I I know some traders use a
second chance entry that if they get
stopped out sort of immediately, they're
ready to get short again.
Again,
you got to see if that suits your
trading.
Um, I don't
it's not for everybody.
Um, but then it sold off down into new
lows down here where you got another
exhaustion print. Um you know, this low
is kind of interesting because it was
coming in hot, you know, minus 400
delta, minus 135, minus 81, minus 72.
Then right here you got a minus 72, then
turns positive 104, 95.
And again, you know, you'd be getting
long right in here.
Somewhere in here in this bar with the
the
high of this bar or one tick off of it.
And your stop just right below the low
of the signal bar with print.
And what happened?
It came right down here,
traded
at your stop price, and then reversed,
and then also went up. Um
again, you know, if you're using a
second chance entry, meaning if you get
stopped out pretty quick,
yeah, you you maybe you want to get back
in. Again, I I'm not recommending that
that's not part of the trading plan, but
I do know that's how some traders are
trading this model. And again, you know,
you get stopped out here,
second chance entry, you get back in
here, then you can catch that move back
up to where you had that short from
earlier, right? Which also stopped you
out, but again, if you're
trading the second chance entry, maybe
you got short again
to capture that move just as here.
You know, that's just how the markets
are sometimes, right? There's just a
little bit leftover buying or leftover
selling that does go and stop you out. I
pretty strict on my stops. Um you know,
I I do like to keep it right below the
low.
I know then again, you know, there's
other traders like to give it a little
bit of breathing room
exactly for this scenario.
But again, it's up to you and and how
you trade it, but generally speaking, I
would put my stop right below the low,
my stop right above the high for
if I'm getting short, okay?
But um yeah, you know, that that was the
two the interesting trades today with
the order flow entry model. And again,
it doesn't take, you know, 5 minutes of
analysis, 10 minutes of analysis. All
you got to do, right, you just keep your
charts open and
you just watch it, right? I mean, yeah,
you can put a sound alert on these
things, but this allows you to watch
different markets. Right, I showed you
E-minis, I showed you bonds, ultra
bonds, you know, even in the tens there
there was a trade today in the tens. Um,
let's go up the tens real quick.
Uh,
want to go to a four range though, not
an eight range on the tens. There was a
trade that uh
started
to move
a little bit in the money
and then went up, stopped you out, but
um
again, you know, what the thing with 10
years,
most of the traders that trade 10 years,
you know, they're they're they're just
looking for a few ticks, they'll move
size, you know, maybe uh oops, it's the
wrong contract. I need this one.
The futures.
There we go, 626. Um
let's just sort of scroll back here. It
was in here somewhere.
Yeah, it did make a move, then some
buying, you know, it reasserted itself,
it came back up again, you know, made
that new high by a couple of ticks. This
is that high that in the bonds and ultra
bonds, you know, showed the exhaustion.
You don't see that exhaustion here, you
actually see very nice volumes, 3,000,
9,000. Um you know, even here is 6,000.
But here was seven.
All right, and you know, you get short
here, you got one, two, three, four,
five ticks.
>> [sighs]
>> You know, that that was a nice trade,
five ticks in in the tens, but you know,
really what you want is this move here
where it's uh you know, from 109 17 down
to 109
07.
But again, you know, this is this is
still a little move here that you could
have caught.
And, you know, the thing with tens, you
know,
it trades a lot of size and
tens have a tendency to attract
size traders, you know, especially if
there's there's scalpers, meaning, you
know, guys that will move uh 50
contracts, 100 contracts, just trying to
get a tick or two. Right? Cuz people
always ask me, "What's something I can
use in the 10 years
to trade?"
You know, really all they got to do, you
know, imagine, you know, it's uh
well, it's 3125
in a whole tick, but in a in a half
tick, it's uh what is that? 156 $15.62,
62 and 1/2 cents.
So, 3125, that's two ticks or two half
ticks in the tens. But, if you're
trading 25 contracts, it's it's 780
bucks right there.
Um
you know, but it it's a nice contract to
trade if if you're
a scalper in the sense that and you're
moving size, right? I mean, if you're a
scalper in the Nasdaq trading one lots,
I don't suggest you go to the 10 years
and start trading one lots because it it
moves much slower.
Um that's why you get the bigger
scalpers trading more size
for smaller targets, okay?
So, anyway, guys, I I hope that video
helps you guys out. You know, again,
it's a very simple setup. Takes just a
few seconds. And the beauty is, right? I
mean, if you got
S&P's, you know, Eurocurrency, bonds,
ultra bonds, you know, you could have
six [snorts] different markets up on
your charts or, you know, on your screen
and just
watch for the signals coming in.
Right? You can have multiple
opportunities in the day.
And just And just [snorts] trade it. All
right? So, thanks everyone, and I'll see
you guys on the next video.
>> Mhm.